I'd love to hear your opinion about the
21st century and whether you think we
might destroy ourselves and maybe your
opinion
if it has changed by looking at what's
going on in Ukraine that we could have a
hot War
with nuclear Powers involved
and the tensions building and the
seeming forgetting
of how terrifying and destructive
nuclear weapons are
do you think
humans might destroy ourselves in the
21st century and if we do how
and how to avoid it
I don't think that's gonna happen
despite
the Terrors of that war
it is a possibility
but I mean I I don't
it's unlikely in your mind
yeah even with the tensions we've had
with this one
nuclear power plant that's been taken
over
um
it's very tense
but I don't actually see a lot of people
worrying that that's going to happen I
think we'll avoid that we had two
nuclear bombs go off in 45 so now we're
77 years later yeah we're doing pretty
good we've never had another one go off
through anger people forget
people forget the lessons of History
well yeah that's why I mean I am worried
about it I mean that is definitely a
challenge but you believe that we'll
make it out and ultimately super
intelligent AI will help us make it out
as opposed to uh destroy us
I think so but we do have to be mindful
of these dangers
and and there are other dangers besides
nuclear weapons so